L
CONSERVATIVE IN THE RACE.
HERE SHE IS.
I'VE LOOKED AT THE POLLS, ITS
NECK AND NECK.
OKAY, THERE WERE FOUR
CANDIDATES, THREE REPUBLICANS
AND ONE DEMOCRAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS ONE OF THE
REPUBLICANS DROPPED OUT, SO IT'S
YOU, LISA MURKOWSKI, AND A
DEMOCRAT I THINK GOT 6%.
CORRECT CHRIS BOURQUE >> THAT'S
CORRECT.
YOU SUMMARIZE THE RACE
PERFECTLY.
>> Hannity: OKAY.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE RANKED
VOTING SYSTEM.
I BELIEVE UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE
TO STUDY THIS TO GET IN SHAPE
MYSELF, THE PEOPLE OF ALASKA
HAVE TO TAKE THEIR FIRST AND
SECOND SELECTION REALLY
SERIOUSLY, DON'T THEY?
>> YES THEY DO.
THIS IS THEIR MURKOWSKI VOTING
SYSTEM, BUT ARE CORRECT ON YOUR
INSTINCT THAT IT WAS HER ALLIES
AND CAMPAIGN STAFF WHO PUT THIS
IN PLACE BECAUSE SHE WOULDN'T OF
HAD A CHANCE OTHERWISE.
ALL PARTIES HAVE TO RUN AGAINST
EACH OTHER IN THE PRIMARY, THE
FOUR TOP CANDIDATES REGARDLESS
OF PARTY MOVE FORWARD.
SHE WOULD'VE LOST HER SEAT IN A
PRIMARY.
SHE'S BEEN CENSORED BY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I AM THE ENDORSED CANDIDATE.
SHE'S KNOWN BADLY IN ALASKA.
>> Hannity: AT LOOKS AS OF
NOW, THE POLLS I'VE SEEN, YOU
AND LISA MURKOWSKI ARE BASICALLY
TIRED.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT WHO WILL
PROBABLY DRAW 6% OF THE VOTE.
SO THAT PERSON WILL BE OUT OF
THE RACE.
THEN IT WOULD BE SECOND CHOICE
VOTING.
IF THERE VOTING FOR A DEMOCRAT
IN THE CHOICE IS YOU IS A
CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL
LISA MURKOWSKI, THE DEMOCRATS
WILL TIP THE BALANCE OF POWER
AND VOTE FOR MURKOWSKI AND THAT
GIVES HER THE ADVANTAGE OR AM I
WRONG?
>> YOU'RE CORRECT.
THEN THE RACE BECOMES A
TIEBREAKER.
ROUND ONE I'M LEADING HER BY
NINE POINTS ARE DOUBLE DIGITS.
IT'S AN ROUND TO WIN THOSE
DEMOCRAT VOTES ROLL-UP, THE
SECOND-PLACE VOTES, THAT IT
BECOMES A NAIL-BITER, CLOSE TO
50/50.
IT'LL DEPEND ON VOTER TURNOUT.
BUT WE'VE BEEN KNOCKING ON
DOORS.
MY HUSBAND AND I HAVE HIT 23
RALLIES IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
WE'RE DOING THE WORK TO GET OUT
OF GRASS ROOTS MOVEMENT.
IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO TIP THE
SCALES.
>> Hannity: I WOULD SAY TO
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF ALASKA,
EVERY REPUBLICAN, THAT THE
SYSTEM IS FLAWED, FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR.
IF, IN FACT, YOU DON'T GET 50%
IN THE FIRST ROUND OF VOTING,
WHICH I URGE PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
YOU FIRST, IN THE FIRST ROUND,
IF YOU DON'T, THEN LIKELY
DEMOCRATS WILL THEN FLIP TO THE
BIDEN SUPPORTING MICHALSKI AND
WORK HER WAY BACK INTO THE
SENATE WITH MITCH McCONNELL'S
MONEY AND IT GOT A LITTLE
QUID PRO QUO GOING BECAUSE
SHE'LL VOTE FOR McCONNELL, AND
SHE WILL ALSO VOTE FOR BIDEN 67%
OF THE TIME WHICH IS A DISGRACE
FOR ALASKA.
>> SHE WEARS THE CHURCHY OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
SHE'S PLAYING FOR PELOSI IN THE
HOUSE RACE.
SHE'S CAMPAIGNING WITH THE ONE
WHO WILL CHOOSE NANCY PELOSI AS
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, THAT'S
NOT GOOD FOR ALASKA.
THEY FLOODED OUR STATE WITH
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DARK
MONEY, MORE THAN MURKOWSKI AND I
HAVE SPENT COMBINED.
WHEN MIKE CAUGHT DOMINIC
McCONNELL SAID HE DO THIS, SHE
SAID, MITCH YOU'VE BEEN THERE
FOR ME, I'LL BE THERE FOR YOU.
WE NEED TO LET ALASKANS KNOW
THIS IS GOING ON.
SEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT, SHE'S NOT
STANDING UP FOR REPUBLICANS BUT
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT.
CAREER POLITICIANS LIKE
LISA MURKOWSKI, SHE IS THE
REASON WHY THE TERM SWAMP WAS
INVENTED.
>> Hannity: THIS IS IN THE
MOST CORRUPT SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW, AND SHE'S NOT
EVEN SUPPORTING SARAH PALIN MY
ADVICE IF YOU'RE IN ALASKA, I
HOPE THEY VOTE FOR YOU.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS NOTHING
SHORT OF DISGUSTING, SWAMP A